Você sabia que tomar 5 HTP triptofano
juntos pode estar piorando a sua
ansiedade em vez de tratar? Se você
sente um inchaço abdominal constante
logo após tomar os seus suplementos para
dormir, ou se a sua ansiedade virou uma
apatia estranha, onde você não tem
vontade de fazer mais nada, pareina
é o hormônio da felicidade, basta jogar
tijolo para dentro do corpo. Mas estudos
de 2024 mostram que se você esverem
inflamada, esse tijolo não vira
felicidade, ele vira uma neurotoxina.
Hoje eu vou te mostrar porque essa
combinação popular pode estar roubando a
sua dopamina, matando a sua libido e
bagunçando o seu cortisol. E claro, eu
vou te entregar o protocolo exato de
como usar isso do jeito certo, com o
pulo do gato que quase ninguém ensina.
Fica comigo.
Para você entender o erro que oito em
cada 10 pacientes comete antes de chegar
na minha clínica, precisamos imaginar o
seu corpo como uma fábrica. A serotonina
é o produto final que a gente quer. É
ela que te dá paz, melhora o sono, reduz
aquela vontade louca de comer doce às 4
da tarde. Agora, para fabricar
serotonina, você precisa de matériapra.
O tririptofano é como se fosse o tijolo
bruto. Ele entra na fábrica, mas precisa
passar por várias máquinas, precisa de
transporte, precisa de autorização do
gerente. É um processo lento e
controlado. Já o 5 HTP, ah, o 5 HTP
diferente, ele é como se fosse a parede
pré-montada. Ele pula várias etapas de
segurança da fábrica e entra direto na
linha de montagem final. Na teoria
parece genial, né, Dr. Alan? Então eu
vou tomar os dois para garantir. E aqui
que mora o perigo. É aqui que a visão
funcional te salva de dar um tiro no pé.
Existe um conceito que você precisa
decorar. Sequestro da via das
quinureninas.
Eu sei, nome difícil, mas o conceito é
simples. Se você está estressada, com
cortisol alto ou inflamada, sabe aquela
barriguinha que não sai? ou aquela dor
articular chata. Isso é inflamação.
Quando o corpo está inflamado, ele pega
o triptofano que você tomou e desvia
ele. Em vez de virar serotonina, ele
vira o ácido quinico.
E o que faz esse ácido? Ele é
neurotóxico.
Ele excita o seu cérebro até exaustão.
Então você toma triptofano para acalmar,
mas acaba ficando mais irritada e com
insônia. Você está literalmente
alimentando a fogueira de ansiedade com
gasolina cara. E tem um segundo problema
que afeta principalmente a sua
motivação. Existe uma enzima no seu
corpo que converte o 5 HTP em
serotonina. O problema é que essa mesma
enzima também é usada para fabricar
dopamina, que é o hormônio da motivação
do foco e do desejo sexual. Se você
inunda o seu corpo com 5 HTP demais,
você gasta toda a enzima fabricando
serotonina e não sobra nada pra
dopamina. E qual é o resultado? Você
fica zen, mas fica sem libido nenhuma,
sem vontade de treinar, sem vontade de
trabalhar. É o que nós chamamos de
dopamine de ou depressão de dopamina.
Você vira um zumbi calmo. E para as
mulheres que me assistem, o buraco é
mais embaixo. Existe uma dança delicada
entre os seus neurotransmissores e seus
hormônios esteroides, o estrogênio e a
progesterona. Quando você desregula essa
balança usando doses cavalares de 5 HTP
sem critério, você pode aumentar
indiretamente a prolactina. E mulher com
prolactina alta, sabe o que acontece? O
ciclo menstrual fica irregular e a
libido aparece. Além disso, se o seu
intestino não estiver bom, o 5 HTP
converte em serotonina no intestino e
não no cérebro. Serotonina demais no
intestino causa diarreia, cólica e
inchaço. Aquele inchaço que te faz
parecer grávida de 3 meses pode ser o
seu suplemento natural. Na visão
funcional, não adianta entupir o
sistema, precisamos modular.
OK, Dr. Alan? Então, como é que eu faço
isso do jeito certo? Aqui tá o protocolo
básico de apoio que eu uso para quem
precisa recuperar o sono e humor sem
destruir a dopamina. Anota aí. Regra
número um. Não misture tudo de uma vez.
Se você usa triptofano, prefira usar
longe das refeições proteicas. O
triptofano compete com outros
aminoácidos para entrar no cérebro. Se
comer com bife, o triptofano perde a
briga. Tome com carboidrato simples,
como meia maçã, 2 horas depois do
jantar. Dose de apoio seria 500 mg.
Regra número dois, o segredo do 5 HTP.
Se você for usar 5 HTP, dos baixas são
melhores. 50 a 100 mg suficiente pra
maioria. Mais que isso, pode ter náusea.
Regra número três, os cofatores
obrigatórios. Lembra da enzima que eu
falei que acaba? Para ela funcionar, ela
precisa de combustível. Nunca tome esses
precursores sem vitamina B6, de
preferência na formativa perridoxal,
cicosfato e magnésio. Eles são os
operários da fábrica. Sem eles, a
matéria-pra acumula e vira toxina.
Agora, a cereja do bolo, aquilo que
diferencia o amador do profissional. Se
você usasp, você quer que ele vire
serotonina no cérebro, não no intestino
e nem no sangue, onde pode até fazer mal
para as válvulas do coração a longo
prazo. Para proteger o 5 HTP até ele
chegar no cérebro, usamos um extrato de
chave chamado EGCG,
epigalato, catequinogalato.
Estudos mostram que o EGCG inibe a
conversão periférica, ou seja, ele
segura o 5 TP, deixa ele viajar pelo
sangue, atravessar a barreira do cérebro
e só lá dentro virar a serotonina.
Genial. Então, procurem um suplemento
que já venha com EGCG ou tomem uma
cápsula de extrato de chá verde junto.
Isso pode mudar completamente o jogo.
Resumindo, triptofano à noite, longe de
proteína, B6 e magnésio sempre junto. E
cuidado com 5 HTP, se você já se sente
desmotivada. Saia do vídeo agora se você
gosta de ficar no superficial. Eu vou te
contar uma verdade conveniente. O
YouTube e os conselhos aqui me limitam.
Aqui eu preciso simplificar, censurar
dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
tem esse filtro. Eu compartilho os
exatos protocolos que eu uso na minha
clínica, casos de reversão que parecem
possíveis, combinações off que funcionam
e fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação avançado de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Nós temos
lives semanais respondendo perguntas,
PDF com 47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo
no WhatsApp, fantástico. Se você quer a
visão funcional real, sem simplificação
para as massas, clica aqui em seja
membro. E não é para curiosos, não é
para pessoas comuns, é para quem quer
resultados. Agora, se você quer ir ainda
mais fundo, existe o nível dois. A cada
duas semanas, fazemos lives de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, desse
artigos científicos linha por linha e
debatendo controvérsias que ninguém ousa
tocar, revelando os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria dorme e assiste
passivamente, você estará ao meu lado
construindo conhecimento de verdade,
tendo o seu reconhecimento público como
alguém que investe no que realmente
importa. Não é só sobre aprender, é
sobre pertencer ao círculo interno de
quem está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm
essa coragem. Você tem? Agradecimentos
aos nossos queridos membros no grupos
avançados de estudos. Cláudia Leitão,
Alex Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular, José
Fortunato Mtinho, FS Machado RJ, Sou
Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Elô Terapias Integrativas,
Saúde Lães da Doença. Muito obrigado
pelo seu carinho, pelo seu apoio.